demonstrations supporting
anti-government protests in cuba have
expanded from south florida
to washington d.c groups gathered
outside the white house and the cuban
embassy saturday
many came by bus from the miami area
limited social media posts indicate
anti-government protests are still going
on
in cuba havana and other places saturday
former president raul castro joined
thousands of people in a pro-government
rally in havana
pushed of course by the cuban government
pope francis
is calling for peace and dialogue in
cuba following these protests
another fact though cuba now has the
highest rate of coronavirus infections
per capita in latin america joining us
tonight florida republican senator marco
rubio member of the senate intelligence
and also appropriations and foreign
relations committees senator thanks for
the time tonight
thanks brett a lot of topics to get to
let's start where we left off there
cuba where you see these anti-government
protests going and what do you think
is possible next well first of all cuba
today is basically in a state of martial
law
and many of the major cities across the
country troops are stationed
security forces are stationed and the
message is clear they're also continuing
to repress people we've
these horrifying reports we've seen and
have gotten of people being tortured
of of people being abducted from their
homes and and
family members not knowing where they
are they tried this is the model they
have followed for a long time the only
difference between now and in the past
is some of it is being documented and
posted on social media for the world to
see
as far as where it goes next look
something changed on the 11th of july
it's
i don't think it's going to happen from
one day to the next it's the beginning
of a process but what is clear now is
that the rupture between the people and
the regime is complete and that they've
lost their legitimacy to govern
and and that's the point that needs to
continue to be driven home they no
longer no matter how you feel about them
ideologically
they no longer have a legitimacy and
it's time for a change to begin on the
island of cuba
and i think from our end the most
important thing we can do is help
provide
internet free unfettered internet access
so the people of cuba
could continue to communicate with the
world and with each other you know
critics i'm saying beyond congresswoman
alexander ocasio-cortez and others
say that for more than five decades
every sanction the u.s has imposed on
cuba
really has not changed uh the party down
there
and uh the leadership and there have
been sanctions that
the critics say have hurt the island
overall but didn't make the change how
do you address that
when it comes to the embargo sanctions
going forward
and what else we can do well i would say
most of the people that give those
opinions don't even know what the
embargo is or how it works the only
embargo
is there's only two embargoes here the
embargo against
government-owned companies and the
embargo that the cuban regime imposes on
its own people
right now if an independent business
operator of a small farm owner
if a consultant or a independent
contractor in cuba
wants to do business with americans they
can there is no restriction on that
it's the cuban regime that doesn't allow
it because they do not want cubans to
own
a hardware store they don't want cubans
to be able to grow food
on a farm and provide it directly to the
market they don't want independent
contractors and consultants to have
american clients because they want to
control how much money people make every
month
it's the leverage they hold over their
heads the people who give these opinions
don't know what they're talking about
they don't know what they don't even all
they know is they're just spewing off a
left-wing talking point
because if you notice these are the same
people that over and over again it's
always america's fault no matter what
problem there is in the world
america's to blame for it america's done
something wrong they don't know what
what the heck they're talking about yeah
last thing on cuba five days ago
uh you you were on this channel you were
talking about the possibilities
of what may happen there here's what you
said about other troops possibly going
in
horrifying this is a bloodbath 90 miles
off of our shores it's destabilizing and
i want to know what joe biden's going to
do
when a thousand special forces from
russia arrive on cuban territory to help
the cuban regime because that's what's
coming next that's what's coming next
do you have any evidence that russia's
on the move there or that that may
happen
well russia is already there i mean they
have a they have an intelligence signals
intelligence station sort of the chinese
but it's the model they've followed
everywhere in the world and it may not
even be directly russian troops maybe
with these private contractors that are
basically russian troops
that they send around the world but this
is what they've done in place after
place in venezuela in syria
and other part in in eastern ukraine and
so there's no doubt in my mind that if
the cuban government
uh requests it the the russians will
provide that
you're the top republican on the
intelligence committee we just did this
piece about china and the concerns about
its cyber activities should the u.s
retaliate
militarily or otherwise to combat
ransomware attacks or other attacks from
the chinese well i think we certainly
have to have the option to retaliate
retaliate in kind in a proportional way
that sends a message about what our red
lines are i'm not sure yet
that there is a clear understanding by
even either the russians or the chinese
about what the american red lines are
with regards to cyber intrusions
you pointed a moment ago to this
microsoft intrusion and there are others
like it
we're entering an era now where you're
not going to be able to attribute it to
a nation state even though they're
behind it there's nothing
that keeps a nation state and in fact
they have every incentive like china or
like russia
to go to criminal networks and say we
want you guys to do this hack if you do
it of course we won't arrest you we'll
even let you keep the money you have
but if you get caught there's not
attribution you can't say it's a
government you could say it's a
criminal organization but here's the
bottom line we are seeing a massive
transfer of wealth
out of the u.s economy into the hands of
these groups that furthers the foreign
policy objectives of both russia
and china this needs to be dealt with
and there needs to be clear it needs to
be clear that there are
there are economic costs associated with
continuing to allow this to happen
in the case of the chinese they are
conducting the most extensive
espionage operation against the united
states in in the history of our country
and it is in every domain electronic and
cyber but also in our universities
everywhere you can imagine all they do
is scoop up data every day and steal our
technology
our intellectual property and collect on
u.s government as well
sandra we're one of the only channels
really that that follows the situation
along the southern border
uh it has not let up uh the illegal
immigration continues a pace
you made an effort on a comprehensive uh
bill years ago to try to to pass one the
president talked about a path to
citizenship today
possibly using the budget bill to get
that through take a listen i want to get
your reaction
we need to find pathways of citizenship
the budget bill
is an appropriate way to get around the
filibuster to be able to make
a judgment as to whether or not they
should have a pathway that's for the
part of
parliamentarian to decide though not not
for joe biden to decide
i mean the fact that he's throwing that
out there do you think that's even
possible
i'm not sure if it's possible i think
it's a terrible horrifying idea let me
tell you why i think the overwhelming
majority of americans would say
yes if someone's been here for a long
time and they're not criminals we need
to figure out a way to incorporate them
into american life
legally but now is the wrong time to do
it simply because we have an all-out
border crisis today there are reports
now of
you know state troopers down there
facing you know these efforts to rush
the border and things of this nature
and and a lot of that is driven by a
misunderstanding of what our laws
actually
are you know in the early days of the
biden administration and even during the
campaign his rhetoric sent the message
to people in central america that the
laws were changing
and they were allowed to come in and the
same has been true with things like daca
it sent the perception and even when
we've done tps and i've supported tps
but when you've done tps
people misunderstand what that means or
they are lied to about what it means
that's what's that's what a a
citizenship bill would do
it would create the perception that our
laws have become more permissive
and these trafficking networks use that
to create disinformation to encourage
more people to undertake this very
dangerous journey
it would be perhaps one of the worst
things they could do right now given the
crisis we're facing on the border
senator rubio we appreciate your time
welcome back anytime thanks brad
hi everyone i'm brian kilmeade i want
you to do me a favor i want you to click
to subscribe to the fox news youtube
page
this is the only way that i know for
sure that you're not going to miss any
great commentary any great
news bites any great interviews coming
your way on fox you can get it all here
on youtube so subscribe right now